hello everyone and thank you for your
extensive and detailed comments about
how the audio in the previous video
sucked I'm referring to the one about
moving pieces and I do agree and I have
tried to improve on this hopefully it
will be better this time it's still the
same sound I did try to mess mess around
what the sounds but I did love it lower
the volume by 50% so it should be more
manageable and now I know we've said
that we well you said that I should
check up on a game by Michael Tao as
today is November 9th it stars birthday
but in the wake of the start of the 2018
World Chess Championship today is Game
one between Fabiano Caruana and magnus
carlsen i decided to postpone at the top
video two for only for a few days as it
is a custom on this channel to do at all
video when this channel reaches a
milestone so hopefully in a few days
this channel will reach 300,000
subscribers and we will then have a very
nice tile video and even maybe a party
but you know we'll see how it goes so
this is a game but in honor of Todd's
birthday I did choose a game from Taos
Memorial it was played in 2012 also in
Taos Memorial and also it's a game from
Carson and Caruana
and I think it will well it will not
give us any idea of what were what we
can expect today but I am interested in
one move that kinda shows how constantly
then and will he play like that now so
let's check it out Carson has the white
pieces and he opens with nice to f3 so
we have the red opening nice to have 6
we have g3 and d5 yeah I just have to
fix the sound although here I were just
gonna fix it by muting it not by
lowering it ok there we have it and we
have d5 the Kings Indian attack is on
the board the yugoslav air iation bishop
the g2 crossing Fieros the bishop c6 and
now crossing castles we have Bishop to
g4 and now comes c4 immediately
challenging the black center we have E 6
and now Karsten does not transpose into
the Slav by playing d4 but rather he
plays this very
very odd seek a person d5 which is very
unusual most of the times you do not
want to break the tension in the center
usually it it it's better for for the
person not capturing in the center but
here across and does it with a very
specific idea for example here if
Caruana plays something like see capture
son d5 den Carson will have this very
nice be five square for his night it
will come with a wooden attack on
Coronas Bishop on g4 also there will be
threats like Queen to a four check also
threatening the bishop here so here you
would have to go back over to h5 and
then white would have a lot of options
here so by playing this C captures on d5
Carson actually forces a this straight
Bishop captures on f3 we have Bishop
captures on f3 and only now C capture
son d5 here across and one the bishop
pair and if he can use them you know I'm
very nice diagonals it will be very good
for white it's okay Knight to the c3
Knight to c6 both players to develop d4
Bishop to e7 we have III by Carlsen we
have castles by Khurana and here cousin
has to figure out still how to develop
the dark square Bishop how to develop
the Queen how to connect rooks and so on
it's very unlikely that you will be able
to push something like e for and then
develop the bishop on this diagonal as
if you ever push C for your d4 pawn
becomes a week so for now it's very
unlikely that this will happen
so b3 he wants to develop it via Bishop
to b2 and okay we have Queen to a5 by
Caruana
Bishop to b2 and the bishop to a3 what
Carson gained by breaking the tension in
the center early on in the opening is
the bishop pair so Caruana makes the
well to me an obvious decision of
getting rid of course since bishop pair
Queen to c1 with Bush of captures Queen
captures and now comes rock ftca and if
you look at this position it's only move
14 but you can already sense that
White's didn't really get anything from
the opening the material on the board is
equal it's two knights against the
knight and the bishop two points on the
Queen side each
the structure is pretty much similar on
the kingside as well and black is even
better in development as his rook
already occupies an open c file so not
really something to be gained but okay
we have rook to c1 Knights the e7 now
Coronas rook is also ready to exchange
down the C file we have Knight to a4 and
here comes Knight to d7 and here if
white were to play well any move other
than the move that was played in the
game for example if he wants to remain
over the bishop to to a better diagonal
then we could see a line like captures
captures and after rook comes to c8
white will improve the position of his
King and then black can also exchange
further and then after something like
Queen to d8 also maybe offer a trade of
Queens but it really unwinds to a very
draw position which would most most
likely be a draw so here Carson doesn't
find a way to push this for win any
further so he tries Knight to c5 a very
interesting move it comes with a pawn
sacrifice but this is something that
happens very often in chess as this is a
town memorial you have to create chances
one must also give chances so let's see
what happens Knight captures on c5 pawn
captures on c5 and rook captures on c5
so Corona grabs a pawn and it's very
interesting what is the compensation
behind the pawn for white Carson had
this in mind we have before attacking
the Queen and the rook but here comes a
rock to b5 so you don't really gain
anything by capturing the Queen now as
you would also lose your queen unbe - if
captures then rook would capture Queen
here so first we have a three costs and
defenses b4 pawn Queen moves back to the
8th and now comes a 4 and well at this
point it was fairly obvious what would
happen most likely this was all taken
into consideration
now if D captures on e4 then Bishop
captures on e4 okay for the price of
this one point perhaps the activity of
the light square bishop would compensate
for the price of one point but Corona
ignores this he immediately goes after
this strong formation a 3b fight before
here and challenges it with a 5 which
makes sense as the pond and before I
still pinned
and the queen is still awkwardly placed
on b2e capture Sun d5 Knight capture Sun
d5 and here we have rook to c5
offering a trade of rooks here if if you
capture rook captures be captures then
white a black would still be up upon but
now you have a weak b7 point which you
cannot push forward due to the c5 phone
and also there's well this rook will be
start defending the a5 pawn so while you
would have an extra pawn it will be very
hard to keep both of them and the light
square bishop now becomes extremely
strong so instead after rook to c5
karana goes for Queen to b6 simply
piling up on the b4 pawn rook captures
on b5 Queen captures on b5 and dena
comes Bishop captures on d5 Carlson
eliminates this night and it doesn't
allow his bishop to ever become powerful
but there was really no other way to do
it
rook to d1 does seem to be an
improvement as it well it seems to be
saving a temple because now if black
does decides to capture on before you
will only then capture on on b5 and then
after pawn captures you will then
recapture here and you will already have
a developed rook on d1 but okay Carlsen
plays Bishop captures on d5 immediately
pawn captures and now comes roof to c1
taking that open C file rook to e8
Caruana develops his rook to another
open C file the open e file and now
comes Queen to d4 a very nice
centralizing move for Carlsen and now
after a cap person before a capped or
some before that was played in the game
we have h6 by Caruana
making some breathing room for Ace King
a nice escape route so there won't be
any back ranked weaknesses if he decides
to activate his rook and here we have a
position where Carson is still down upon
it will be very unpleasant to play this
of course white cannot play this for a
win the position is pretty much the same
three points on the on the King side
each each one point on the Queen side
each but the differences Corona has a
very nice past deep on which he will of
course tries to push and here across
some place a very interesting move he
plays king g2 which is a waiting move
but also a very tricky move here it
seems like rook to e4 should win you the
game for black
as the Queen now has to move then we'll
capture spawn and you were up to pawns
you have to pass pawns of course you
will be winning this but this is
actually a draw by force I have to rook
the ch-check King h7 and the now comes
rook to c5 and here we have a very
interesting position where if Queen
captures here then Queen captures here
and then which ideas of Queen to a5
roped the c8 and the Queen also putting
pressure on the b7 pawn now white would
have more than enough resources to ever
to draw this game also black cannot
start pushing the pawn as the 5th rank
is covered very nicely by white but also
interesting even if you don't go for
this Queen captures pawn if you go for
something like rook captures Queen then
rook captures on b5 you're gonna
eliminate the b7 pawn so whatever black
plays you will simply capture now it's a
completely wrong game both players have
a nice pass pawn and it's a draw so
after this King to g2 not to look to e4
immediately but first karana improves
with b6 taking away the c5 square for
Carlson's rook here a very nice move we
have rook to d1 and now comes Luke to e4
finally mm defending the pawn would rook
to the 8th would make little sense
because now both the rook and the Queen
are stuck protecting this past point you
will not be able to push it and black
really can't make any progress here so
perhaps this would still be playable but
you would have to Riemann over
everything so after rook to d1 rook to
e4 in the move we've already mentioned
Queen captures on d5 we have Queen
captures on d5 rook captures on d5 and
now rook captures on b4 now we have this
end game where both players have 3
points on the King side and it's a
rookie against rookie with one extra
pass pawn for Caruana so let's see how
he does this here
h4 by Carlsen a very interesting move if
Carson starts immediately would look to
d8 check King h7 and rook to b8 put a
rug behind a passed pawn
then g5 will be a very strong move for
Caruana taking away the h4 + f4 square
the f5 pawn can come with a very nice
expansion and then the the rook will
help out escorting this past poem so
before doing all that first cousin goes
h4 take
away the g5 square for Coronas g5 move
and now we have came to f8 Caruana
starts bringing his King into the game
as this is what you want to do in an end
game we have looked at these seven rook
to e4
now comes rope the b7 of course you have
to put a rope behind a passed pawn
whether it's your own pawn or your
opponent's pawn we have rook to e6
defending the pawn and now comes g4 and
now it's very interesting how do you
push this you can't start pushing your
beep on and well you can't bring your
King into the game so it's very
interesting how Caruana does it g5 of
course the king will come into the game
via the G file and now if you play H
captors and g5 h captors and g5 + f4
then you get G captures on f4 King to
have three and now if the rogue decides
to defend this pawn then g5 is a very
nice move and this would have been one
way to play this line and white would
most likely be able to hold this but
here across and played the immediate f4
but now it's a bit different because now
karana plays G captures on f4 we have
King to have three and now rope to have
six defending g5 now of course karana
does not capture because we get to the
exact same position we've just analyzed
but after g5 he simply moves the rock to
c6 King captures on f4 is played now
comes a move that is basically the only
move that would allow Khurana to push
for the win here but feel free to pause
the video here as this is one of the
position that might occur in your own
game so you know it wouldn't hurt to
know how to handle it for those of you
who were able to do it who have paused
the video and sold it correctly
congratulations you have found the only
move in the endgame that allows the
black to push for the win and for those
who just want to enjoy the show the move
is h5 not exchanging and lowering the
chances for a for a win but here you
take away the g4 square from White's
king and the rook is cutting off the
White King completely from the 6th rank
and the pawns really can't go anywhere
so white is really out of options here
cross and is go King to a5 but now comes
King to g7 bringing the King into the
game
rook to b8 White has to play some
think we have roped the CFI with check
King to f4 and now comes look to b5
putting the rook in front with the past
pawn for now King to e4 now comes rook
to be one black is ready to start
pushing his passport came to f8 else or
King to a5 and now it came to f5 comes
with a trick if you play b5 now it
wouldn't be the best idea because now
cousin could have played this rook to b7
move and if you start pushing your
passport then g6 would be of course very
strong if rook f1 checked because you
cannot capture the rook is pinned from
the rook on b7 so after something like
rook to f1 check King moves rogue g1
check King captures you would capture on
g6 and rook captures on f7 this a very
nice tricky move would be available for
Carlson to draw the game because after
Keane captures on f7 it's a very nice
stalemate the White King has nowhere to
go but ok after King to f5 rook to be to
first a nice waiting moved by Caruana
and now cousin has to waste a move King
to f4 and only now rub the b4 check we
have King to e5 if King to g3 for
example then the King is cut off from
this rank and you can start pushing your
pawn so after work to before check we
have king to e5 and now Kings to g6
finally Caruana brings it skin closer
and now we have rook to GA check King h7
now comes rope to f8 attacking the pawn
and now finally rook captures on h4
rook captures on f7 King to g6 and now
rope to f6 check if you try to go the
other way
for example rook to b7 then you get King
captures and g5 rook characters but now
I have to rope the c4
the king is completely cut off from the
H bone black will simply push it and win
the game so after king to g6 we have
rooked to f6 check King captures and g5
by Caruana and now comes rug captures
and b6 now it's a past H bomb the king
is somewhat cut off and it will be very
instructive how Caruana plays this rook
to a for making room for the pawn so it
can go forward we have rook to b8 and
now King to g4 look the g8 check of
course came to a three rope to F a check
came to g3 and now
rook the g8 check King to h2 and now
King to f5 approaching the past pawn h4
we have rook to b8 and now comes h3 and
here we have King to g5
it's interesting how do you proceed if
rook to be to check if rook to be to
check then you have to move around a bit
but after King g3 rook checks King moves
rook block spawn now you will play rook
to a1 and now you will prepare to move
your pawn either by playing it either by
going rogue g1 and blocking it would
rogue g2 or if white continues for
example with check then you will simply
bring your King closer
for example rook b3 kingi to rock b2
with check king g1 rugby 7 trying to go
behind the passed pawn now but now
simply h2 and now after roof g7 check
King of two you can promote your pawn
into a queen simply grab it grab it
and then white the black will of course
be able to checkmate the white king but
after h3 we have King King the g5 now
comes Luke to e4 King to f5 and now rook
to e2 not allowing any checks Rock the
g8 and not allowing the King to move
over to the G file rub the g2 blocking
we have looked at the eight and now we
have an excellent opportunity here for
you to actually not win this game here
if you play something like King to g1 it
would actually be a drawn endgame you
would not be able to win this anymore
for black for for the reasons that
follow white would play King to f4 and
now if you try to push her passport for
example h2 you would get rook to d1
check King to f2 and now there is no
more way for you to actually promote the
pawn the rook is controlling the h1
square and if you try something like
rook to h1 then how can black proceed
you cannot approach the pawn with the
King if you go up to g1 or remove the
rook anywhere white will simply capture
the pawn and if you try something like
Kim to e2 then of course you get rook to
a-1 and now Rock did you want it's
pointless because you get
rook to a to check King moves and rook
captures on h2 so it would be very
unfortunate to actually blunder the game
like this with King to g1 but
Korona played roof to have to check and
it was in this position that magnus
carlsen resigned the game unmoved 62
because it doesn't matter how he
proceeds if king g4 for example kingi -
there are no more checks the king is
blocking all the checks from the G file
you will simply pull the pond and win
and if you play something other than
that maybe king e4 again King g1 and it
is all over
whichever check white decides to give it
will be all over as the rook can simply
block and then you will promote this
point into a win this is also a very
nice position I might even use this for
a thumbnail but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and something I
wanted to talk about it was a
disposition here after we've mentioned
it sorry about that
after this night the d7 we mentioned
that instead of this night the c5 cost
and probably could have gone for Bishop
to e2 or something and go into a drone
endgame so he had the white pieces he
wanted more than a draw and he really
wanted to push for a win which is very
interesting because in an interview
Qasim gave a few days before before
today he said that he finds it really
difficult to go for a win in in
positions that don't really have a lot
of chances he can't force himself to be
creative and you know take these really
slim chances and create something out of
nothing but it's very interesting here
he tried with this night to see if I
move will he try in the 2018 World Chess
Championship match we will see as I've
already mentioned today's game won and
I'm very eager to see how it will go
after I upload this video a video I am
leaving Heathrow going for all born and
I will I'll probably have a cup of
coffee there and I do have I do have a
ticket for today my friend even knew
which invited me well he actually got
the ticket so he offered me if I wanted
to visit and basically it's one of the
reasons why I decided to come to London
but also I've never been to London so it
will be a very nice
but mostly I came for chess of course as
you all might have imagined but yeah you
know really really looking forward to
this and uh one more word about this das
memorial even though they really battled
it out neither carson nor Caruana
won this tournament carson was second in
this tournament but the person who
actually wanted was the person whose
quote i've chosen for this game the good
thing in chess is that very often the
best moves are the most beautiful ones
the beauty of logic and that person of
course is this person you all know him I
don't think he needs any further
introduction it is Boris Gelfand
when he was younger but still very nice
photo sir I would like to thank damn it
watch what it's a William Gould
Jonathan Cornell bolshakov Keitel and
Otto brand for a contribution to my
channel thank you what I really
appreciated as usual you can check too
on my previous video see our thing
called for watching and I will see you
soon
with Game one of the 2018 World Chess
Championship match and be sure to
mention if the sound was better in this
video thank you all and I will see you
soon